Buenas tardes acaba de firmar una
declaración conjunta en que se muestra
el apoyo inquebrantable sin fisuras a
Ucrania en un por parte de los líderes
aliados que forman parte del g7 son
siete países que han firmado una
declaración de este apoyo a Ucrania se
trata de un apoyo a largo plazo en que
se ofrecerá a Ucrania un paquete
financiero y también militar también de
ofrecer todo tipo de material militar
ahora mismo para hacer frente a la
agresión de Rusia pero también se trata
de desarrollar también capacidades en
materia de inteligencia también
industrial y también en ciberdefensas se
trata de un paquete muy amplio en que lo
que se trata es de ayudar a Ucrania lo
máximo posible mientras está esperando
para poder entrar en la alianza para el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
se trata del de una muestra que Clara
del apoyo que tienen los países aliados
Ucrania además en este comunicado se
asegura que en caso de que Rusia vuelva
a agredir en el futuro a Ucrania con una
futura guerra Se va se van a tomar todas
las medidas legales
respectivas y también se van a hacer las
consultas necesarias para saber cómo
actuar en caso de que Ucrania no forme a
un parte de la alianza este plan firmada
ahora mismo por los países del g7 es un
plan aparte que se ha producido en los
márgenes de la Cumbre de la otan esto se
suma a los planes anunciados ayer de una
de un apoyo también militar financiero a
Ucrania y esta invitación para que
Ucrania forme parte del futuro de la